Hi, I don't know if you can hear me.
I don't know if this sounds okay, I'm a bit low.
Hello.
You can hear my EC, it's quite loud, but do you like the white noise or is it bothersome?
I will keep today, thank you.
Hello.
I am trying to add to the effects.
Okay, wait, do I sound okay too?
I think I look nice.
Okay, I just want to make sure.
I'm very excited, I have on my desk so much stuff.
You can call me big sis.
Pretend you can't see my ball gang under my neck.
No, no, I'm just myself today, I'm just wearing a different outfit.
Hello, you guys like the new emote?
Let me see if I can fix that real quick.
You might hear some water in the background, that's my cat's water fountain.
Hold on, I'm taking off my, taking off my, my cat, the clown is your favorite emote.
I'm very licensed, I'm a licensed esthetician.
What the heck?
There we go.
That's better at least.
Yeah, the really intense crying one is one of my favorite past PL emotes and so I had to bring it back.
One of my done doing my makeup, you've only one makeup twice in your life.
Well, I love makeup, I love it a lot actually.
I don't really wear makeup that much anymore because I don't leave my house, but today I'm going to be doing your makeup.
I'm going to be giving you some personal attention before I go.
I hope you enjoy it, since I leave tomorrow for my trip to see my family.
I'll be gone until the 23rd and I'll miss you guys a lot, so I thought I'd be nice today.
And I kind of walk you through like a skincare routine and then I'll brush your hair and do your makeup, give you a little ear massage.
Oh yeah, do you ever do your makeup just to sit around the house?
Yeah, I literally put on like a full face today to get my nails done when I really didn't need to.
I did light blue for my nails and I kept them a shorter length, I didn't do them super long.
So they're nice, they're cute little almond nails.
A little picture from after stream.
Yeah, I'll miss you guys.
This includes, yeah, yeah, I'm going to do your hair, I'm going to wash your hair, I'm going to brush it.
You're going to do a lot of triggers today.
Yeah, I hope you guys enjoy, I hope my AC and my background noise like my cat eating right now is a bit too distracting.
I'm very nervous for tomorrow because I fly out, my mom's bringing me to the airport.
I'm very anxious because I haven't flown in a very, very long time and I don't like traveling by myself.
So of course I'll remember you, you'll be all that I'm thinking about when I'm gone.
It's going to be so hard.
But when I come back, I have a special, special, sorry that was boomy, a special Twitter space I want to do on my alt for you guys.
I had the idea and I was going to do it today but I'm like nah, I'll do it when I come back.
Another thing, I want to apologize in advance because I never recorded the ASMR video that I was supposed to and so it's definitely not going to be edited in time for my absence.
But I do have some shorts coming so I hope you guys like the shorts.
Yeah, and I'll probably do a Twitter space while I'm there and talk to you guys.
I'll be active on social media.
Yeah.
Well, I miss you guys a lot.
Yeah, I'm going to be really sad without the kitties.
What?
What is that, Emote?
What is that?
Oh wait, that's the, it looks really weird reflected on YouTube.
The little pen lights look really fucking goofy.
Some of these translate very weirdly on YouTube but it's fine.
Let me tweet that I'm live.
You don't see anything in my hand.
There's nothing there.
Okay, let me just...
Um, Boomi is running in circles around the couch. She seems to be having a good time.
Oh, we hit 11k followers on Twitter! Let's go!
That's awesome. That's so cool.
And we're so close to 10k, guys. I'll probably be 10k in the middle of my trip.
Give me some ideas for 10k.
Um, you say...
Oops, I can't type.
Ow, my nose!
Okay.
Maybe tweet this on my own.
Maybe Endurance or Donut request ASMR stream?
Maybe.
That's good.
Evil witch ASMR roleplaying for the time being.
Yeah I think I honestly have to credit um the clipper who clipped us cause that video
of like the adult youtuber agency that has almost 100k views and youtube has called us
um a few times so I might be called again but um it's just really incredible how just
like a clipper channel that just takes interest in you can really support the growth and I'm
very thankful for that um he discovered me via that video yeah I love reading the comments
on that video and people are really funny people think Azera is faking her voice which
is I think is my favorite cause that's just how she actually talks she doesn't point
on a voice or anything.
I don't know why youtube keeps calling us um again the AI thinks that it's not appropriate
growth it thinks that it's not real so it is what it is um I don't know why I'm so anxious
I'm feeling very shy.
Well me can you please stop I don't know if you guys heard that.
I hope I won't have to congratulate you we might actually I won't be surprised if I
dip below 10k and then get back up to it and she's very excitable right now.
I think in the next set of emotes that I get I'm going to um get like Bumi and Fia and
Reina emotes I think that would be fun uh you know what I realized I will probably have
to recolor my emotes once I get my tan tongue oh that's gonna be interesting isn't it cat
you both you both yeah I also want to get an emote that says bark um what are you eating
oh mom he's eating something I think it's a dog
he was excitedly running around with a piece of cardboard in his mouth I don't know which
video was it that hit 100k oh yeah it was made by osmovie osmovie made a highlight reel
of all of the allure's debuts and um they're a popular uh youtuber channel and uh yeah
it's almost 100k do you want our makeup already patience young padawan kind of animals Bumi
uh I have three simies cats I see there's actually a lot of new faces um today so if
you came from the video hello uh hi my name is shimi cottonbomb I'm your favorite girl failure
dom I am the bunny dom on natrix of the alerts young one and I love to do wacky voices I love
to do roleplays I'm very good at improving I'd like to think um don't look up the cottonbomb
family tree that's all I have to say I have uh three cats they're all simies cats um and I make
content on patreon uh once a week and it comes out every thursday so you'll keep getting a video
tomorrow and use code uh shibi for 10 off of gamer subs because I'm also a gamer subspartner um but
yeah it's not bria it's fia fia is named after uh the deathbed companion from out of the ring
which is my favorite game uh boomi is named after boomi you know wumashu and rena is just rena
she looks like a little fluffy rain cloud so her name is rena
yeah we love we love gamer subs here we're a gamer subs household don't bring in any other
that other junk into this household otherwise we're gonna have some issues um but today so I'm
gonna I usually like to chat a little bit before um I stream uh and then you guys can get all settled
in and comfy um I like to let people kind of trickle in um and uh yeah he's a you know the
simies cat so they do be speaking and um I'll be doing a couple things I mentioned earlier
wow my arms I'm gonna put this off to the side for now so I don't have to worry about them
uh cut the stream oh no I left it in because johnny says she wanted to clip it so
uh I haven't played the new visual novels but I want to um let me get uh blue twitch
next month I want to be do reading some uh spicy vms that would be very fun
so I'm gonna be doing your makeup
and so I was gonna I'm just gonna wait another 10 minutes I like to like chat for 30 minutes
uh if you're new here you probably don't know that I am quite the yapper
hi miwa hi miwa miwa miwa please check out miwa um mostly stream on uh twitch
they also make amazing uh ASMR related streams and she's also a cute little
she is funny funny girl she's so adorable not for you to know you're stingy
um but yeah I'm just kind of letting people you know get their you know wait wait a little
bit so people can come in hang out but um yeah if you're if you're new here I really hope you
enjoy uh I do yeah I chat a lot I've done like a endurance streams where I just talk for seven
hours and play the game for two um you shower today uh are you sure you cleaned everything
mister I don't even know what that so are you I'm I smell delicious today I did my hair I got my nails
done um yeah
she reads on that yappathon
can I get a little bit no no no I think you guys I think you guys think I make way more money than I
do
I'm feeling nice I'm feeling cute my hair is nice and fluffy my nails are nice and blue
how do you have a dye I smell good I shave my legs today
my legs are super smooth I got baby smooth legs
hi hi make a cup of me I need to be a lot bigger and make a lot of sales for that
but if there's a cottontail VA cup then buy that one
I'm gamersless I just I'm just gonna pretend that we're distantly related
so
boomi is peeing right next to me you might be able to hear him pee I'm sorry
good job that boy boomi
what a good boy
they're cussing it
oh thank you Smokin Nate for the 20 gifted um just because I'm in the precursor chat um
I'm gonna I'll be able to read out donos but when we actually get into the ASMR in about eight
minutes I will leave the donos and the gifted and the soup was at the end okay but paulgers
thank you so much um yeah oh yeah I wanted to get look cute for you guys today I wasn't
initially wearing my normal outfit but then I hopped on booth and I was like let me get a cute
outfit to wear for you guys do you want me to see uh well I might this might ruin the effect
but I only have the top half of me transparent um and the rest of me is still there but I'm wearing
a little shirt and you know shorts it looks like there's two people on screen and then I'm just legs
I didn't I didn't want to bother with let's follow that
um wait I don't know this the dress but I like the casual the casual fit is cute I like a casual
fit it does look like a cardboard cutout or it looks like I'm just like creepily standing behind
someone like there's a girl that I'm just bought um yeah I got this off booth I like the the outfit
and I um the uh little makeup assets you see here
um they are by kevin art kevart on twitter um really amazing assets I can do really cool
stuff with this I'm excited you can see I can move it around wow
I can tap it I can also add makeup to my face but I'm not going to do that because I'm doing
makeup on you today um I'm wearing no shoes I'm sitting here with no shoes
um
hips don't lie um I am also talking in a higher pitch today because I'm a little shy right now
again you guys know that the blend speed comes out when I'm
elevated feelings of emotion so uh I know you probably want to
you know the mommy mommy voice I don't even think I can do it right now to be honest with you
um have a good have a good sleep thank you thank you so much all right
okay how are you guys are you guys doing okay I know you guys are kind of sad but I really
I really um hope that you guys don't feel too bad when I'm gone because I I'll miss you guys too
it's fun you guys don't this is closer to my it's like it's weird I don't know why I made that noise
um people like at my voice changes depending on stuff and like sometimes I'll have like a deeper
voice like when I was playing with mercy yesterday and then when I'm alone with you guys I just get
all like
chibi chibi
oh and my heart and my voice I really do the shy shy be cuddle bum
cuddle bum I actually like that
uh but yeah so
cuddle bum I'm related to a strongy when I'm cuddle bum
the bun I'll never lose but I'll be really in character the entire time um
I was debating whether or not to be like one of the sisters of the cotton bun family but I'm like
I don't feel like doing all that because then people are gonna ask me questions about
inappropriate questions or something about my lineage and my family relationship
so just pretend I'm a younger sheebie from another time this is before the days of running
hotel wonderland hello welcome in um I'm about to start the improv
but uh so you are my sibling and I'm I'm using you as a little makeup dummy so
you know hi foo hi uh have a good rest of your day people who can't say but thank you for stopping
by I appreciate you 17 years ago when I was 30 because I'm 56 I can't do math that one but you
guys get it I'm very excited I want to I want to just turn my whole life is a good stuff yeah
so um it's going to be a lot of personal attention I'm not going to be like me or anything
I could have done like a mean girl doesn't even make a role play but
I just want to I just want to treat you today I saw a tree treat treat treat treat
you might be considered a hag but hacks good
what the heck is that what's not like hags normally don't get wrong what are you talking
about oh so you guys like my bedroom yeah so this is my this is my bedroom I got a
I got a a little mirror I got my laptop I love the color green this reminds me a lot of my room
I got my little study lamp all I see is a cat and more plants
yeah
no you won't be a mess you won't be a mess
and I actually really like this casual outfit I'm not gonna lie to you I might wear this more
often happy I got this this is a cute little shirt
okay you guys ready we're gonna start we're gonna start
I'm gonna launch right into it and I won't be reading oh I'll be reading chat because you guys
will be able to like talk to me you know you're like ah you're poking my eye I'll be like shut up
oh no I'll make sure I put waterproof mascara on
I'm not gonna count you down oh I don't know how much time is left I think it just turned
into fortune I still look the same woman este lauderdior
all right
all right you're probably you're probably wondering what you're doing here
yeah yeah I know I know
chibi I have homework to do whatever this is more important okay I have very important
things that I need to practice and none of others should bring that around so it looks like you're
stuck with me I was watching a lot of youtube tutorials about how to do uh skincare and makeup
so I'm gonna try that on each day
you know you don't have a choice you thought you had a choice I'm so sorry no no kiddo I'm sorry um
my sweet sweet sibling uh hey you know you can sit back relax it'll be fun
you hate makeup it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter can I do this on myself it's it's easier if I practice on something
and then I'll do it on myself you know mom said I would be a great makeup artist do you see my works
no I don't look like a clown when I put on makeup see this is why I have to practice
okay the important part of good makeup
is having a flawless base
I'm sorry if I pop to you crumbs you're just too far away I have to move forward
so I need a flawless base and to get a flawless base I was watching I was watching a tutorial
we gotta do like skincare so I got a bunch of skincare stuff from like the drug store
no I didn't do drugs at the drug store why are you so annoying
yeah I wish there was somebody else I could do this on but you're the only one here so
everybody else is out with their friends but you're just you're just stuck doing homework at home so
whatever
when I'm done you want to show mom yeah we can show mom I think mom would like it
I'd also like to try my stuff on mom but she says that um she has like a work
conference and she doesn't want me to mess stuff up or use her more expensive makeup so
I just got this stuff I got like some let me I'll show you I got
some I got some elf products and some maybe foundation don't worry I got made sure it's
the right skin tone for you don't worry we're pretty close in skip so I got some facial spray
I got some skincare stuff
it's really fun to tap on with my nails I got my nails done
I just got some
mix eyeliner
um I also got you know my favorite brand of color pop so I got some color pop
brushes
and I got I'm even trying out my favorite palette on you
I love color pop a lot and so I'm gonna use my favorite palette on you and it's gonna be the
early mom chalwell palette that's really nice um as like a lot of bronze you have some cream you
have some um like earthy tones and you got like a splash of blue I think blue would look good with
your eyes you don't think blue is your color well that's gonna change the races um I also got some
lip gloss pretty good
um I've got a brand new makeup sponge
oil it's pink and new so squishy
um I also got some face oils and creams
so I'm gonna um they're gonna wash your face because you're kind of grinding
and like affectionately though like you look great but it's like I need to wash your face
don't sit still I want to need you to sit still can you sit I need you to sit still can you sit still
stop fidgeting if you keep fidgeting it's not gonna work thank you
okay
don't bite your nails it's not good for your teeth
yeah she's gonna play pokemon go just just go on your phone
stop moving you're making me get water on myself
okay
close your mouth you can breathe I know you can breathe
it's only a little cold because it's moving there was warm on it
your phone died you can hear how to take my charger take take take take my charger
I said close your mouth see that's what happens I just I use got water in the mouth
no I'm not waterboarding you stop being so dramatic
you
you know our other brothers and sisters want to be so complaining they'd be so thankful for having
me wash their face
it's thirsty
oh you gotta spray water in your mouth so I hope you have it
you know what I should have made you bring sacks before you sat down
please don't tell me you have to pee because I'll be very pissed
stop touching my ears you know I don't like it when people touch my ears
but I'm gonna hit you you can't cry mom's on around
okay
here I have I think I have like a pack of skittles
here have a have a skittle eat this
what are you doing
why you don't bring them all in your mouth I thought I was sharing with you
and now there's skittles that are over the you're hopeless you're absolutely hopeless
I can't give you that okay let me wipe your face
was the last time you washed your hair
two weeks ago
what is even in your hair right now this is gum am I gonna have to cut your hair
oh my god
four days ago
right this is why you get lice every year you're not washing your hair
you have to you know
I can't tell if you have curly hair like me but I really wash it
on my hair I conditioner every other day and then I'll do shampoo once a week
it's called a cold wash so I recommend that if you have curly hair I can
stop moving
yeah you can wash your chest conditioner
stop stop I'm not I'm not even touching your hair I'm gonna touch it though because it's disgusting
I can't believe you want to go to school like this
everyone says you can't wash your hair you'll turn into your group who who told you that
was it the philip kids they're just they're crazy
apparently their mom does crack so I'm not even worried about what they have to say
okay
oh it's cracked don't don't worry about it don't tell mom I told you what that is don't
don't don't don't don't don't worry about it okay um
why did you turn your face into it keep your head still I just sprayed you on my face
just not have to wipe your face again
trying to wet your hair
no it's going in your nose
you are impossible
okay I think I wet it though
okay
let me get the brush
if you start crying I'm gonna be so mad
okay so I got the brush here I'm gonna start brushing your hair
when you brush your hair you want to start from the ends and work your way up
you don't want to start at the root otherwise you're gonna have more hair breakage okay
can you nod
stop crying oh my god you wet your face
why are you so impossible
if you have longer hair
I'm wiping your nose you're good yeah you can mine those run
nope all of my hair is in this let me just take my own hair out
no yeah I'm gonna clean the heck out of this brush when I'm done with it
because I don't know if you're nice again
okay are you ready
so I'm gonna have you hold it at the base so no take your no give me your hand
give me your hand so you're gonna put it like you're gonna make a ponytail okay
you're gonna put it like you're gonna make a ponytail at the root near your
weekend's golf hold it and then I'm gonna brush from the end okay
if your hair is long enough hi hi oh hold on I got a text from my my friend strong
it says she's she's sending people over to us oh that's me
how are you doing
all right let me brush your hair
don't move I'm not giving you ponytails stop complaining
yes I'll text I'll text you on your back if I say thank you
why is your hair so knotted
I'm not gonna give you cooties
I'm not pulling your hair
I'm gonna have to like
probably braid your hair so it doesn't stay like I can I can play it for you
because I don't I don't know
need to if you're gonna weigh your hair down you gotta brush it out
you
ah giant freaking knot
stop crying if you pull away it's gonna hurt harder
you
I'm an older sister I'm not a mean girl stop calling me a mean girl
but because the kids at school say I mean it doesn't mean you need to call me me
you
yes I'm gonna do your makeup and you're gonna be so cute everybody's gonna be following
right now we have a lot left to be desired I mean wow you look so cute already wow mom's
dreams really wore off on me
I
let me just move your hair out of your face I know you think you're like emo or whatever but
you're seeing what does that even mean
I'm glad the kids at school say I was really what oh my my kids at school don't say anything
I
why are you making that face
see does it know it feels good to have your hair brushed when it's mostly brushed out
now it feels like before you're just screaming and crying now it feels better
you
let me fix your part your part your cow look did you know you have a cow look
no it doesn't mean a cow look do it it's just it's just expressions
it's okay if you're a crybaby you're my crybaby
don't tell the others but you're my favorite simply I'm kidding you smell
no don't talk about it I'm kidding I'm teasing you relax
you
thanks for that text strongy uh strongy text me she want me to tell you that don't forget to like and subscribe
and use code 10% off for all gamer subs purposes coach duty I don't know what that's about funny text
you
I think I missed a knot
oh you can hold my hand go hold my hand hold my hand hold my hand okay
I'm gonna get this knot out it's gonna be fine it's okay it's okay don't worry don't cry it's gonna be fine
okay I gotta see see it wasn't that bad it wasn't that bad it wasn't that bad
okay it's not gonna give me wow see you're fine you're fine
see it wasn't that bad it wasn't that bad you're not gonna go bald
okay now that I brushed your hair out I'm just gonna let your hair air dry um
I think I don't want to like use my hair dryer on you it'll be too loud
so now that
we did your hair we brushed it out it looks nice it looks so nice down really really good um
now I'm gonna do your skincare okay
so um I'm gonna go and already washed your face so I'm going to use a chemical exfoliant
this is what I watched on on on YouTube
so don't worry a chemical exfoliant isn't bad it's fine
so you have a very unique um balance on your face and so you want to balance your AHA
and your um BHA on your face um it's better to use a chemical exfoliant than a physical
exfoliant because physical exfoliant can make micro tears in your skin and the micro tears in
your skin can cause acne and cause your skin to be very sensitive um so I'm using uh Paula's Choice
exfoliant on your face it's not gonna burn
I'm just gonna put some on this cotton pad
okay I don't have a lot of product left in us
it's fine I watched it on YouTube it's what the beauty guru told me to do
no I know you normally use soap and water but sometimes just soap and water can dry out your
skin and you want to make sure you're fully at your skin otherwise you're gonna get black heads
and white heads and acne and I'm trying to help you okay it's also good for discoloration
so let me wipe your face close your close your eyes close your eyes
good goodennnina
close close close c c c c c c c c c c
c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c cigh
okay good good good good good
Good, good, good, good, good.
Well, now, keep your head straight.
Don't open your eyes.
Do you want me to poke you in the eye? It'll burn if it goes in your eye.
You can't peek. I'm not peeking.
This is what happens. You have to hold your head straight.
You're doing a good job.
So I'm using a cotton pad and I'm just wiping this along your face.
Cotton pad or cousins also? I think we do have a cousin in cotton pad.
Don't turn your head. Stay still. I need to get a spark by your nose.
See, it doesn't have any on eyes to be peppered.
Please do not sneeze in my face.
Hold on. Is that cotton on your face?
Okay, I think it's good.
So now that I put the chemical exfoliant, I don't want to put on a serum that's another type of exfoliant.
I'm not going to do lack of the gas or anything.
So I'm just going to go in with just a caudally serum.
It's a Xenome Perfection.
It smells good. I'm going to put it a little bit more.
Okay, I'm going to tap this on your face.
It smells like flowers.
You want to pat it and you don't want to rub in the serum. You always want to pat your serum.
Okay.
Nice.
Now that I've got a serum on your face, I'm going to put on a...
Let's see, what is this called?
I'm going to put some sunscreen on you because no matter what skin tone you are, sun is very powerful.
You want to avoid skin damage.
Let's shake it up.
This is Innisfree sunscreen.
That's beautiful.
It smells like flowers.
I'm going to dab it onto my hand.
Okay.
I'm going to rub this into your skin.
You always want to make sure that your skincare dries down before you go on to the next thing.
Okay.
Get some more.
You want it?
The trick is with sunscreen, hold out your...
Yeah, give me your hand.
Give me your hand.
I'm not going to bite your hand.
So what you want to do is you want to hold out your first two fingers, so your index finger and your middle finger.
And then the amount of sunscreen you want has to be aligned on both fingers.
And then you can...
You want to incorporate that all in.
Even if you're dark skinned, you need sunscreen.
You can still get skin cancer, even if you're brown.
You can still get sunburn, even if you're brown.
Okay.
I think I put too much on my hands, but your face is fine.
Let me go wash my hands.
Okay.
Why are you still here? I thought you were going to run away.
That's right, I locked the door.
Um, as dark skin this is cat.
They don't know that I'm also brown.
They don't know that I'm brown.
Um, anyways.
So the next thing I'm going to do is I'm just going to put on some lotion on your lips.
That's not the lotion.
That's the lotion.
Did you take the lotion?
Give it, give it back.
Sheesh.
You want to use a non-fragment lotion, just something basic, like CeraVe.
CeraVe is really good.
Because sometimes the fragrance can irritate your skin.
Make sure that when you select a, um, what's it called?
A lotion.
You don't want it to have like the first thing, sometimes it's alcohol.
And the ingredient list, you don't want it to be alcohol.
If you're, if you're very acne prone, I recommend doing a spot treatment of Penoxel.
Um, that's the brand name.
But it's good. You don't want to put it all over your face because it can dry out your skin.
But you can just dab it on.
I don't have my normal lotion, so I'm just putting on bath and body on you though.
Normally I wouldn't put this on my face, I'll just put it on my body.
Because your face skin is very sensitive.
It smells very good though.
It's a thousand wishes.
Okay.
Kiddyl, you look like you're really up and sleepy.
Do you like putting lotion on your face?
That's funny.
Are you falling asleep?
I am falling asleep wake up.
Wake up.
Nightmare, nightmare, nightmare.
I can't get more of the lotion.
I know about the different content.
You never want to put any sort of oil on your face
because I can clog your pores.
Coins I have to put.
I've got a serum.
I need to put a serum that helps with your pores.
It's called Nekamad.
Nekamad.
Go away, go away.
Go away.
I want to use my headscarf with a free bottle.
You know we have four layers of product on right now.
You just have a toner, which is the Paula's Choice.
You have a serum, you have sunscreen, and now you have lotion.
Go away.
I'm almost done rubbing it in.
Just a little bit longer.
Go away.
I'm going to use this to rub it in.
It's so watery.
Let me wipe my hands off.
Okay.
Brush.
This is more than it.
Yeah, yeah, I love you too.
I just want to say thank you for helping me out with this so far.
Your skin is looking really nice.
You look like you're going.
Okay, we think you need the makeup, but that's too bad because I still want to practice.
Okay, so now that we did your skin care, I'm going to do your makeup.
So first, when you do your makeup, you want to start with the primer.
I'm going to use the NYX primer.
No, is it Elf or NYX?
Sorry, it's the Elf Supergrip primer.
It's the blue one.
It's really good at holding your makeup in place.
At least that's what the YouTube videos have.
Okay, so now I'm going to do your skin care.
okay, let me put this.
oops, so sorry.
I'm gonna cut a little Tine, just like that.
just going to rub this into your skin,
into your skin. I'm just gonna kind of like pat it.
I'm sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. It's okay. It's okay. Don't cry. Please don't cry.
Okay. It's okay. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Yeah, I'll take you for ice cream.
I can't. Come on. I'm kissing your ear better.
Stop crying. Yeah, I'll take you for ice cream. Please don't cry. I'll take you for ice cream.
Yeah, you can have whatever flavor you want.
Okay, a bottle.
I'm gonna wipe my hands off.
Now that we have your skin primed, I'm gonna go in with the foundation.
Normally, I use new personally. I use S.T.A. water, but for you, I'm not gonna use a $50 foundation.
So I'm gonna just use the Maybelline Fit Me foundation. I can get like, you know what I'm saying?
And it is matte, porous, and it lasts 12 hours.
I got your skin tone. So it should be a good match.
Yeah, makeup's really expensive. You have no idea how much I spend on makeup.
That's why I haven't been wearing it as often. That's why I've been trying to shop for more drugstore brands.
Because usually, there's an expression in the beauty community called a dupe.
So the dupe is usually has like the same formula, but it's not like the super big name brand.
But they're very similar. They might be like one or two key differences.
But otherwise, they're essentially the same.
That's a good question. Why am I painting your face the same tone it already is?
So this is gonna even out your skin tone, because not everybody has flawless glass skin.
And if you wanted to like, cover up any deeper pores or any acne scars or anything, that would be good.
Sometimes people will use a concealer first if they have like, it's called under-concealing or under-painting.
So they will conceal the spots first and then they'll go over with a foundation.
I prefer to do foundation and concealer mostly because I don't really have a lot of spots to cover.
I'll just do concealer under my eyes, because sometimes I like dark circles because the concealer doesn't sleep well.
On the left, get this.
Like priming a wall before painting is a good question.
You don't want a little bit of concealer though. You don't want a lot of concealer.
I'm gonna go into the concealer first.
I'll look concealer under your eyes.
Why would you spend so much on makeup?
Okay, mom's spending a lot of time on makeup.
Okay, I won't tell mom this and that.
I think, I don't know.
There is like a, sometimes a definite difference in like, more expensive makeup.
I only really get the more expensive stuff for like, certain things.
So like, I'll get an expensive foundation because that's the thing that I'll be most seeing on my face.
But then everything else, I'll be like, very cheap.
Like, I'll use, like, I like color pop a lot because they're really good for nose or stuff.
But they don't break the bank.
Like, I got a lot of blushes and eyeshadow palettes from them.
But yeah, I'll get like, a really nice foundation and everything else.
I'll be like, drugstore brand.
I think that's what a lot of people do too.
Of course.
Happy time.
Okay.
On the dress.
I'm going to go on with my fingers for this.
So for me personally, I go in and put foundation on my face with my fingers.
And I kind of finger paint it on.
But then, I pat it out with a makeup sponge.
Usually a wet makeup sponge.
It just makes it, um, it's really good for liquid makeup.
Uh, just to kind of like, I don't know, make you have like more glowy days.
I know you can't use crayons.
I know you eat crayons.
No, you can't use them on your face either.
That's on that side, and I'm just going to rub that into my face.
Lightly.
You told me the people on the internet.
Really, you've got to do what works for you.
It's a lot of trial and error.
Um, and I've changed my makeup routine a lot over the years.
Uh, I've also tried to put crayon on my face.
You might be able to do pastels, like actual wax pastels, I don't know.
Oh, you can eat them.
Please don't eat them.
Uh, no wonder why the kids at school think you're weird.
I mean, what?
Um, there are like makeup sticks that look like giant crayons, though.
It's kind of funny, they're just like foundation sticks.
Probably even a marker.
Yeah, that comes off with alcohol, though.
Yeah, I know like, oh yeah, a lot of beauty.
And you just like swipe the stick on your face.
I don't use that though, because it just doesn't work for me.
I don't know.
It feels weird.
I don't like heavy makeup.
I like makeup that feels light.
I like using the milk brand for makeup.
Um, but they're expensive, so I don't really get them anymore.
I used to get their Sunshine Skin Tint, but that thing was like 40 bucks.
Okay.
So, I already have all that makeup sponge here, so I'm going to dab this and kind of blend it.
So I'm going to blend this into your skin.
Don't move.
Close your eyes.
good job
good job, just a bit of sound
just a bit of sound
do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do
can do this side, can do this on the side
Keep it close, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go
Boss.
Okay, that things up and it out really nice
um, I'm gonna conceal under it.
I had a little bit.
Did you sleep last night or are you out playing games?
You're mom, you know mom doesn't like it.
I'm gonna play games.
Oh my god, I'm gonna stub this. Oh no. Cool.
You know you're not supposed to stay up late. Don't stay up late.
I'm mixing up the concealer. Mixing up the concealer.
Okay, I think I mixed it.
Where should I go with this?
Should maybe go under the spine.
So usually I blend out my concealer with the same sponge, but I'm just gonna use a different brush.
Okay, don't move. Don't move, don't move, don't move.
Okay, I'm gonna put it right under your mouth.
I'm gonna put it under your nose.
Okay, thank you for not moving.
okay let me do this over here don't move don't move don't move
i don't want to poke you in the eye please don't move don't move don't move
okay perfect okay so your base is done
the base is done perfect perfect okay so i'm gonna really you can go in any direction sometimes after
people do um their base they'll do their eyebrows or they might do their eye shadow
or and do their eye makeup or do their balls you can really go any way after this i'm gonna do
eyebrows um your eyebrows i need to be plump so let me just i have some tweezers i think i'm
gonna poke your eyebrows please i'm just gonna pull it you have a urabra let me just
poke it i need to see a poke i'm gonna poke okay all right good don't move it'll hurt more
do this one do this one
don't stay still stay still
so
okay you did it you did such a good job i know i know where i know where i just noticed a couple
of tweezers i should have tweezed them out here but i forgot i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay okay so we do your eyebrows i have um where is my eyebrow pencil so you can use
like a pomade that sometimes i use i used to use anastasia but i really use eyebrow pomade
now i just do that for my eyebrows and test it a little bit and i'm just gonna use
there you go i forgot to grab it pomade don't move don't move
okay
so i have a the mix my eyebrow pencil i'm just gonna pull in your eyebrows real quick did you like
shave your eyebrow off by the way did you
maybe shave your eyebrows actually before i do do that i'm gonna set and you set your foundation
i'm so stupid okay i have long marcia translucent setting powder
i'll do your eyebrows after i set your foundation because the eyebrow pencil is gonna slide around
if i don't set it with the powder
here
because i put a liquid so setting this kind of makes it more stable it makes it not want to move
i have my brush here
okay so i'm gonna
setting powder
and i'm gonna put a little bit under your eyes just to bake under your eyes a little bit and
what baking is it just it's a longer time to set so the makeup does increase
so it fills it all the gaps but you have my skin you don't have any wrinkles or bad pores so you're fine
i'm gonna tap off the excess
and it's gonna
i'm sorry i didn't mean to pull out your ears
keep your eyes closed
so
translucent setting powder it's good to get either translucent powder or powder that
matches your skin just because you don't want to end up like change trials and look like the
spider from whatever ttb show was where you just have like it's called flashback face
you're like hi sisters are you just scary buddy
what happened to me i remember i was out with my family and i think they took a picture of me at
church and my face was just like white my neck was brown because i put the wrong um setting powder
on and it looked really funny
right now i'm just gonna brush it off
my day is going well thank you
i'm gonna sat nice on your face so i'm just gonna brush it off
emi it looks like she wants to come over and she's bringing friends hello ragers
i'm currently setting your makeup setting powder
hello hello hello hello hello hello hello hello hello hello hello i hope you had a good time i hope
you had a good time i hope you had a good time did you have a good time with me did you have a good
time with me
oh too much makeup long-term ruined skin that's a great question sibling um it actually won't
as long as you properly clean it off if you can't put on makeup every day and you didn't wash your
face then yes it will damage your skin but nothing in makeup um can really damage you unless you're
allergic to like a fragrance or something i like a something within the makeup otherwise you should
be fine i've been wearing makeup for 50 years and i look great
how are you doing the bells are you doing how you doing i hope you're doing well i hope you're
doing well i hope you're doing well
well for example you pass out without falling asleep without taking off makeup um that's a
great question you might wake up with like a bit um because it does it can clog your pores if you
don't wash it out um but if you wake up you said to wash it off in the morning it shouldn't cause
any long-term damage i've fallen asleep with makeup on before from the morning i just like wash my
face really good exfoliate put all the gunk out i'll usually take extra care um and do a little
bit extra steps in my skincare routine whatever really happens i think it's only happened to me
like once or twice um even if i'm like not feeling good i usually i will always take my makeup off
um if you're wondering how to wash your face after you have makeup on because you're probably
wondering oh she you just did a primer to really make the foundation stay you just set it to your
skin how am i supposed to get this off well there are special cleansers you can get get it off usually
oil based cleanser um oil cleansers are ones that are good for your skin and when i say like
don't put oil on your face i mean like paper that's not the same type of oil that's a heavier um
it's like a it's a mineral oil with fragrance that's not what like a facial like a cleansing bomb does
um yeah my cellar water is good no not all of oil um as you know actually eggs are good for a
face mask eggs are very good uh do not put mineral oil on your face please that will clog your pores
um you can use makeup wipes so what i do i use um do not clean your face with vegetable oil um
i usually go in with the makeup wipes and i wipe my makeup off of the wipe and something like that
actually i have some makeup wipes right here
and this usually has like my cellar water in it oh no i don't have contact
let's go for wipe let's go
um
and after that i'll usually go in with a salic acid cleaner so that sounds scary when it is but
again um salic acid is a chemical exfoliant um that is okay and safe for your skin and small
doses so there's a certain percentage of acid in there um and so i'll do
just makeup permanently okay it's fine um
you know don't put gas when you're running in here and um
and uh i usually do that uh do i usually use um what's it called the ordinary
no it's the balm i have called a good old cleansing balm
hold on now i need to work it's gonna bother me
it's gonna bother me oh i'm getting big don't worry about it stop stop getting big
okay
it's called the anti-wrist so for skincare the anti-wrist that you can get like
Sephora or i think Ulta as well um i don't remember but uh the ingredients and the ordinary are
very affordable um and they're the basic of the ingredients so that's definitely crazy
okay i don't know what about me
and um
um
i use the old cleansing balm from that and then i wash my face with the old cleansing balm
i double wash
but again you also don't want to over wash your face because if you over wash your face you can
also strip your face of bacteria that needs to be on your face um and it can mess up your
skin so you want to make sure you use the right stuff to clean your skin
because you don't want to strip it of its natural oil and then the dryness um can make you break
out as well because then your body overcompensates for the lack of natural oils and begins to
over reduce oil you don't want that to happen
so that's why you don't want to just go in with like a hand soap and water because the hand soap
is meant to strip any bad bacteria from your hands and it won't dry out your skin and that
um you don't want to use that on your face because it's hand soap
if you have a good type of soap that's hydrating and then you put on lotion afterwards then
you're fine but sometimes um you want to make sure that you hydrate your skin
um or use like a hydrating cleanser or hydrating soap otherwise you don't dry out your skin and
it will cause more quick gout okay now that i set your makeup your foundation i plucked your eyebrows
let's go in and actually do your eyebrows i'm not filling in
so i need to make it bigger the crayon part is pretty small it's kind of like a pencil
it's called the mix micro brow pencil
you don't want to use a five in one face wash because think about it your skin on your body
your skin on your face um and your hair you're all different um your skin is a giant organ
it's the biggest organ in your body you want to make sure you take care of it accordingly
and if you use the same product i don't know it's not going to have the same effect
so yes cleanser toner serum sunscreen motion yes exactly good job
okay so it turns out i am using this to wash my face in the morning
yeah no soap not soap soup
i've been drying out my skin it's not the acne only some more acne took it yeah
so your body will overproduce oil and it'll clog your skin so if you just get like a nice
base like again sarah v um i'm gonna give you guys some typical drugstore brands
so if you get like uh love rose poise uh sarah v um
let me see
see the fill is really good you also want to know everybody's skin is different um so i have
combination skin uh so there's uh there's dry skin combination skin and oily skin um so i have
patches of my skin that are dry and i have patches that are oily um so you want to make sure you
have a cleanser for that but if you really dry skin you want to have a more hydrating um water
based uh um cleanser and and if you have a um oily skin you want um something that won't be as
heavy on your skin otherwise you're just gonna clock it up again uh so yeah and you also you
might have sensitive skin it's a lot of trial and error to get the right uh type of um skin
care routine that's why i really like seida fill and sarah v because uh you can get like a gentle
foaming cleanser to start off with and um you can kind of work your way up from there
and then like i used to have oily skin but now i have combination skin yeah vino is good
ole dove dove is surprising is like dove is trusted and true yeah skin ph exactly
um your diet does also factor in uh don't wash your please don't wash your face with hand soap
again when you wash your face with hand soap your hands come into contact with lots of different
bacteria you use that to maneuver things in the world it's a very harsh soap because your hands
can handle it um because that's what they're meant for but then your face it's not meant for that
i'll put it on your face
do not put hand sanitizer on your face that just lets it burn um you can spot treat
if you're gonna spot treat something um you can put like a little dab of a witch hazel or a little
dab of um alcohol like rubbing alcohol just to dry it out um but you want to do that if it's not
if your skin isn't positively um reacting to that then stop you really want to try you want to
test stuff out you never want to go in put something all over your face you want to spot check stuff
otherwise um you might irritate your skin and you don't want to irritate your skin
like i love um miyana and i love her uh lingerie brand the savage xfifty um she also has a skincare
brand uh i have a friend and her skin works amazing with her skincare brand but then i discovered
that i am actually allergic to something in her skincare when i tried it out she had really awesome
toner and like lotion and stuff but i don't know what i was allergic to
and it would make my skin break out even more now that's just me it works for other people
it might not work for you it might work for you
sorry she be society doesn't advertise to guys how to take care of your skin
yeah that's because for you guys from men it's mostly focused that you you know eat well and you
look good physically um in terms of like your body type um for women it's really our face and like
i'll wait so i'm not um they don't usually um uh they won't i know like some brands like they'll
advertise stuff like my dad is a very meticulously groomed man sometimes i'll make fun of him for
that and sometimes my mom does but he like my dad will do his skincare um and stuff too um
and he'll do like an under eye cream and then do like a special lotion um also if you're elderly
like myself i'm 56 um you want to you can add like a serum if you get like a retinol cream
a retinol is really good for anti aging um you want to i highly recommend there's a i can't remember
exactly what it's called but there's a cycle you want to go through when it comes to your skin
care for the best results um and you want to cycle through the serums use i'm not going to get into
all that you can just youtube that but there is like a cycle women are just very more particular
about how we groom ourselves because again we groom ourselves for men um and then obviously
for ourselves as well because what makes us feel good but um and a lot of female feminine products
were created by men so it's very interesting but then the men don't use that for themselves because
normally it doesn't affect them as much because again our hormones um
are different than men men like we both have testosterone and estrogen we do some different
levels it can be expensive but um there are so many budget friendly uh routines you can do
whether it may be for makeup or for um what's it called or for skincare like i didn't come out the
gate using like tart and like really expensive makeup and skincare brands oh i just want to
like cvs or ride aid and just like got the basic stuff that's all you really need yeah it's chemistry
yeah that is the pink tax that's usually well i'll buy like some men's products like i'll buy
men's deodorant and i'll buy men's razors because women's razors are also not as well made
same with the deodorant and um they will be a lot more expensive like one razor for a woman
might be like 20 bucks but for a guy who'll get like three for the same amount
um and really again i will recommend for like budget friendly stuff i like sarah v and setafil
um you can just search like 13 best 12 best 10 best drugstore brands
does it men's deodorant smell like men yeah but my hair products overwhelm what my armpits smell
like so you only really smell my hair and my hair smells like candy so i still smell like a girl
i want to do a face routine but i'm scared i might ruin my face more i guess i'll just water um
um actually if you you know there's stuff in your water right like if you use just half water
your water can be hard it can have like um different ph levels in it that can also dry out your skin
three and one stuff is bad don't use three and one stuff if you're gonna get get get separate
stuff you want something that will specially shampoo your hair you don't want to use the same
stuff on your hair as on your body it might not be as effective i swear so
but um if your skin is sensitive then you need to act accordingly
so i'm just tapping on this pen it's on the tap on with my hair
i'm just gonna brush
my brows a little bit they're a little bit wild
what's nice about this next thing is that i can um it has one end be the pencil and one end be
the brush i can just brush it
but honestly i bet that i don't um again i only know like girl recommendations so
if you want me to guys i can i can do some research for you and i can make like another
doing your like face and skin um but i can cure it specifically towards men um
not that this won't work for you but i'll just specifically use like men's brands um and if
you have a beard maybe you'll like like i'm in the beard oil or if you're bald like a bald man
oil doesn't an electric razor work for a body here too so you don't have to get so many disposable
ones um women don't really get marketed electric razors men do for when they shave their beavers
and stuff but women don't
okay now that
uh
do light strokes
short light strokes
i remember i like got manscaped for myself because again i wanted like men's razors are
significantly cheaper now i just use drill it men's razors are significantly cheaper than women's
and i don't like manscaped because i kept making my kuchi anytime i tried to shave
and i kept cutting my legs on accident so i don't know if the blades were so sharp
i want to try getting a single blade blade single edge whatever those things are called
you know how hard it hurts so much when you cut your pussy lip it hurts a lot guys
well there's me using all the things seems more than against nobody's skin is different
what will work for someone will not work for you what will work for you might not work for
someone else doesn't miss sharing my knowledge you don't have to change anything it's just
suggestions and recommendations and sometimes it's also down to genetics like it's that simple
like you might not have to do anything you just wake up throw water on your face and you walk out
the door and that could be genetic me i'm more acne prone um my mom still has acne and she's
in her 70s and i'm 50 um and i just never went away and so i get the occasional breakout when
i was normal when you're in an age when you're a man and a woman um you stop breaking out but
genetically just don't so i try to do preventative measures to stop really bad breakouts
sometimes it's a hormonal thing um so like for example i'm on medication for um
my acne because i'll get it like on my body that's annoying because i can't i told you guys
like i scar easily so like you know red dot for me it just turned into a brown dot and so i'll
just have like spots and i'm like i'm a leopard so i'll take i take um like a antibiotic and it
actually kills the bacteria that makes um okay so your eyebrows are nicely filled in i gave you a
good arc um so now i'm going to put a little bit of a primer on your eyelid and i'm gonna go with some
eye shadow yeah yeah i totally feel that um and that's another reason why i i'm very self-conscious
about my skin so that's why i don't know what anybody see me no man will perceive me or gaze upon me
i'm an idiot no he doesn't see me but like no i'm a woman i have womanly thoughts
but i'm much ferocious so i look like a hunchback another day
much brush that i use so i'm gonna tap this close it can you close your eyes
can you close your eyes
close your eyes can you close your eyes close your eyes close your eyes
close close close close close close
okay so i'm just gonna pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat
no wonder you're wearing this entire time i forgot to use this
um
i don't even know if i'll get that
i'll put the compact away
um
i want to get my real close real close i'm on the pad pat pat pat pat pat pat pat
i'd like that
okay
so now i'm going to put some eyeshadow on your eye
so i have my
sorry i'm sorry maybe because i'm leona i have my
limoncello palette from um
color pop this color pop is my first eye shopper i'm gonna read out to you the names
and you can tell me what you want me to put on so we got
some right always be serenade best mom let me squeeze a cup or eight on just
did you get that
did you get it
is it i can say it again
i'll repeat it okay
so
yes there's easy one then squeeze it so easy peasy i like i use easy peasy on my eyes a lot it's
like this almost like bronzy green undertones but it's like i wish i had my um my camera set up
because then i'd show you guys what it looks like um and it's very pretty very beautiful very
beautiful let's do it let's do a little swatch a little swatch okay so i'm gonna use lemon
squeezy as a base it's like this golden color um and then i'll put easy peasy which is like a
shimmer on it and then i'll kind of contour your eye with um a little bit like a little bit of
smoke for the with tusk and phone and best but we do
tap on that
that song
okay so
yeah tap off the excess hold on
okay
and
i'm
okay it's a brush
Where's my blending brush? I need a blending brush.
Yeah, so I'm just gonna blend, blend, blend, blend, blend, blend...
Cos you don't want it to clump in one spot, we don't want it to clump in one spot.
Perfect! Perfect, perfect, perfect.
Okay, it looks really cute.
So I put the base down, so I'm just gonna go in with another brush.
Cause I don't want to use the same brush.
I really keep my brushes separate.
I have a lot of different types of brushes.
Usually girls don't always use the same brush.
We use lots of different type of brushes.
Oh, is there a peelio on this one?
Oh, the ones I never took the peelio off of this.
Right here, there's a really nice peelio.
Oh, that was great.
Wow, this is...
Ooh, that looks good.
Oh, there's a peelio in the mirror.
Wow, that looks so cute.
Oh my god, why do I look so cute?
What the hell?
Okay, sorry to get distracted about how cute I am.
Okay.
I'm playing and...
I need to put on some chapstick.
Oh.
Okay, I'll put on some chapstick later.
I'm still looking at my lips for now.
Okay.
Let me get some more.
Okay, I got some more.
So I'm gonna brush easy peasy over your lid.
Um, put on some...
Just a little bit.
Sorry.
Don't move.
Close your eyes.
Close, close, close, close, close.
You better be close, close, close, close, close, close, close, close, close.
Are they closed? Are they closed?
Go ahead
Done
Cool
Okay, that looks good
That looks so cute
Oh my god, okay
I'm gonna go in with a little bit of Tuscany Gone
and that's what I'm gonna mix
I'm just gonna do outside corners of the eyes
A little bit of smoke
Just a little bit of smoke
Okay, perfect
Okay, now that we've got the eyeshadow
Usually you want to do eyeshadow before you do eyeliner
Otherwise, you're just gonna go over your eyeliner and that's it
So I got...
I don't know what you just...
Okay, got the eyeliner
So this is a pencil liner
Actually, it's like a marker, you know what I'm talking about?
So, usually, I personally don't like pencil liners
I prefer liquid liners
but everybody is different
So, what type of eyeliner do you want?
Do you want like a little wing?
Do you want like a big cat eye?
I can do like a little bit
like little wings on the other
and like mine
Do you want to like mine?
Because I have pretty good eyeliner on my eye
My eyeliner is one for you
as a kid, so...
You want like me?
Okay, I'll do like me
You have to...
You can't move
In fact, I need a whole new one
I need to shake this up
So I'm using NYX Professional Epic Ink Liner
That's the one I use a lot of proof
And it is pretty good
I'm gonna shake it up a little bit
Okay, one of those
I'm just going to...
Hold me up, like hold you
Okay, so I'm just a little wing
Close your eyes
Close, close, close, close, close, close, close
Hold on, close, keep your eye
Can you like...
Yeah, just like, yeah, like that, thank you
I'm just gonna fill it in a little bit
I don't really kind of miss a spot
Okay, perfect
Okay, let me do the other eye
Other eye
Just gonna go in
Close, close, close, close, close
Holding you down
Perfect, and done
Nice, okay
I thought you were gonna move
And make me go across your face
So I'm happy that didn't work out
That made that work out
Let me...
So now, what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna get some mascara
Yep, don't you worry
So for mascara, my true...
Why don't I...
Oh, I got the brush
The mascara I've used for years
Is roller lash by Benefit
It's my favorite
Hold on, let me get the mascara out
There we go
Sometimes I'll put it on my top and bottom lash
But really, I've been just doing my top lash
I have naturally super long eyelashes
So I usually get asked if I wear falsies
When I use this mascara
I don't use falsies
I just have natural and curling and long eyelashes
Thank you, genetics
Okay, this is gonna be very hard
Because you have to look up
So you have to look up
So look up
And I'm just gonna wipe this under your eye, okay?
So, please, you...
Ready?
Which one do you want me to do?
Which one do you want me to start with?
My left eye? Your left eye?
Okay
My left or your left?
Ready?
Look up
Oh
You moved
Why did you move?
I just poked you in the eye
And you have mascara on your nose now
God, sweetie, why did you move?
Okay, hold on
Let me wipe it
Look up, look up
Do you like that?
It's okay
I'm gonna get a little bit of cleanser
And then I'm just gonna wipe it
I told you not to move
Okay, you're fine
Okay, let's try this again
Let's try this again
You'll be okay
Okay
I'm gonna do the other eye this time, okay?
So look up and just don't move
And then as I'm moving my hand
You can slowly blink, okay?
Ready?
Like this
Watch, watch me, watch me
Watch me
So I'm gonna look up
Look up
You got it?
What if you're blind and cancel or I'm looking?
How are you typing?
I'm very impressed
Okay, perfect
Okay
Good, good, that worked
Next one, next one, good job
Okay
Nice, good job
Nice job, nice job, perfect
Oh, my mouth is open
So
Now you did that
Nice job
I think I'm gonna add some blush on you now
So let me get
Nope, hold on, let me find the right one
Got it
Alright, hold on
Let me close it
Okay
Oh, sorry, I had to go somewhere
Don't look at my boobs
That's weird
I'm your sister
Kind of awkward
Okay
Cool, cool, cool
Alright, I think that's good
Oops, what am I pressing on?
Alright
Don't
Stop looking at my boobs
Alright, let me use
Why are you just
Why are you just staring?
Can you please stop?
That's very appropriate
Okay
My god
Alright
So you got your blush
Okay, I think we need to give you a nice whip
Like
A little whip, a little
A little whippy whip
A little, oh
Sorry
Alright, come here, come here, come here
I need it
Alright
I need a problem
Lipstick
I can find the lipstick
Sometimes these towels don't work
Oh, found it
The lipstick hasn't found
Alright
Using
I think that's nice
Mm-hmm
So before, actually, I put lipstick on you
I'm gonna put on some chapstick on you
Because I'm gonna
Hydrate those lips
Can you push your lips like this?
Well, push your lips
Like that
Please
Please, please, please
Can you
Can you give me a kiss?
I know you like to
You wanna give me a kiss
Okay, perfect
Okay
Let's first
Now I'm gonna put my lip on your chapstick
I'm gonna put on
The lipstick
So
First
Right now
Okay
Mm-hmm
Perfect
You smack your lips there like this
Mm-hmm
Okay
Have a kiss
Come on, you wanna give me a kiss
Come on, Ricky
Give me a kiss on the tree
Right there
Aw, I see that wasn't so hard
Good job
Nice
My hand is small
Sorry, let me back up
Nope
Um
Don't look at that
Nope
I'm tilting myself
Uh
Don't worry about it
Um, okay
So now I'm gonna set your makeup with the setting spray
Just another layer to lock it all in
Lock it, lock it, lock it, lock it, lock it in
Lock it in, lock it in, lock it in
Yes, I'm wearing good at cartwheels
Lock, lock it, lock it
Pop, lock and drop it
Lock it
Okay, so I like to use
The collier
Oh, debout beauty mixer
As a setting spray
It's also good just for like
Just to spray on your face
Just to kind of re-energize it
Sorry, I'm just shaking it up
Because the product is all separated
Okay
So let me just
Nice
It also smells good
What's in it?
Um
It's too small, I honestly can't read that
It's also dark
What is this font?
Water
Citrus
Something in Latin
Rosemary, leaf oil, potassium
I can't tell
And you don't want to touch your face for that?
Um, alright
You know what it should have done?
I should have contoured
But it's fine
You don't really need contour
I don't like contour
You don't need contour
Alright
What do you think?
Take a look, here
I'm handing you the compact
What do you think?
I think you look really lovely
Yeah, hold on, let me get out of the way
Let me let me let you look in the mirror
Let me let you look in the mirror
Why don't you walk over to the mirror
Wow, you look so good
You look so amazing
Wow, I
You look so good in the mirror right now
Are you mewing?
Have you been mewing lately?
You're mocking everybody
You look like a model
Have you ever considered becoming a model?
Your eyebrows are on fleek
It gave you that good arch
Bust your hair out so you look nice
You're perching your lips
You look really good
You got really nice lips
I don't even have to contour your nose or anything
You can see a little bit of a shadow
I kept it nice and light
And it really goes with your outfit
Wow
Come back come back here
Come back over
Nice, nice
I think I did a good job
What do you guys think?
Wonderful features
I don't know why you don't have everybody
Boys and girls, you know
Blasting after you
You look gorgeous
Now you can get everyone
You can pull any fit bird that your heart desires
Wait, you have a crush on somebody?
There's a girl that you like
Tell me, who's the girl?
Who's the girl that you like?
I hope they treat you right
Otherwise we're going to have problems
I don't want to have to
Have to take care of anybody
It's me?
That's really sweet and all
But um
I'm your sister
Well
I do admit that it's very sweet
That you admitted to me being your crush
You know it's kind of wholesome in a way
I'll give you a little smooch for that
You look really good
Good luck getting that all off
I actually tattooed it to your face
So I guess you're permanently gorgeous
So
The plot twist of the century
Yeah, it's permanent
It's permanent
Hold on, I have an idea
Nobody move
Nobody do anything
Frick
Where is it?
Oh, I found it
Hold on, hold on, hold on
Please hold, please hold
Please hold
I kind of wish I found this earlier
Because that would be funny if I just had this already
Wow
Oh
Uh
Where are the toggles on this?
Are there any toggles?
I don't think there is
Hold on, let me throw this away real quick
Hold on
And I'm not giving myself a base chat
Sorry, it was going under my clothes
There's like something you can do
There's like more you can do
I don't know why the toggles aren't working
Is it over here?
Nope
What if I, what if I, let me go into the file
I look like I'm getting tattooed
No, it isn't supposed to be like this
I'm the one who tattooed
Let me give myself a cool face chat
Let me give myself a beard
That would be a fun ASMR stream
You're tattooing me
And I'm like an annoying client
There's a way that I can like tattoo
Oh, she on my chest
So I can't figure out how to do it
Hold on, let me see
What if I load
What are the hotkeys for this?
I wish I would let you see the hotkeys
What's it called?
The live 2D assets you load in
Alt F4, do you think I'm an idiot bro?
Ow, I just like hurt my nose
Yeah, you're being welded
I'm tattooing some makeup on my face
There are people who actually, what is happening
There are people that tattoo stuff
What if I just go through all the letters
I will find these toggles
As if it's the last thing I do
Okay, they don't want to work
Maybe I loaded it in wrong
What if I load this as a model
No, that wouldn't make any sense
Did I put this on the wrong folder?
Oh, if you haven't noticed, it's the end of the ASMR
Demos
I can have Drake or no regrets
tattooed on me
So I can't figure out how to do it
Customize
Kevin makes such great assets
I wish I would
It's like not showing, whatever I give up
But you get the idea, you get the meme, you get the joke
Property of Madame Sheevee in my bag
Yeah, it was better, it was better
I would give you a tramp stamp that says
Omega
And I'll get one on my front
Where a boom tattoo that says Alpha
Never mind
I'm on YouTube
Did you guys like the ASMR?
Did you like it?
Did you like the ASMR?
Did you like my AC ambiance?
Did you like my outfit?
I realize I'm very thick
No, ignore that my outfit is over my normal outfit
What happens if I
Let me just go back down
No
I like that my neck stayed in place
That's because
I usually load in my head as a model
But this time
I just
Loaded in my normal self and just made my top transparent
I
Normally
I just do this and I slap that on
Hey look, it's me and the
It's me and Bethany
Hello
Hi
She looks like a little parrot I can put on my shoulders
Shebethany?
Sorry, I threw Shebethany away
Erm, what's the shibbity?
The actual shibbity? Is that Bethany?
Shibbity
Oh, I still haven't finished my immortal now that I think of it
We have to finish it, we have the last, like, I think, 15 chapters to do
And then Shebethany will disappear into the ether until I find another fanfiction
I have to go pack
I'm glad you guys liked ASMR
The fanfic? No, Twilight's not a fanfic, that's a book
But yes, I'm glad you guys enjoyed
No, you're thinking of Fifty Shades, love, you're thinking of Fifty Shades
Ugh, I guess I'll be all dick, okay, so I gotta go
I gotta go pack and I have to go call my mom
This is the part where I leave you guys
Oh, this is hard
I'm not gonna, hold on, let me switch to my normal mic
Let me switch
Okay
Hi
Sorry
Is it too loud?
Okay, I was like, I haven't changed anything
Yeah, it's louder because it's my normal mic
I shouldn't have done that mic warning, I'm sorry
I just turned this off, why is it still going?
I don't know how this still picks up
I turned the power off and OBS still picks it up
So yeah, so I'll be gone, I don't know why I'm like tilted
Why am I tilted?
You spin me right around, baby, right around
Like a good baby, right around, round, round
But
So yeah, I'll be gone for a little bit
Hope you don't miss me too much, because I know I'll miss you guys a lot
It's gonna be really hard to be gone
Again, I'm gonna try to be super active on socials
And
I'm really bummed out right now
Because you guys know I wanted to stream for you all the time
It's hard not to be there
My tears don't fall down my face anymore, I don't know why they broke
But I love you guys a lot
You know that it's gonna be super hard for me to be away from you
And I never can ever do
Oh yeah, people, it's been a month, it's been a month
Guys, it's been a month for members
Take care of yourselves, I'm leaving
I'm leaving the girls in charge
So behave
I was about to read Dono's, but thank you for yelling at me
I'm just saying, just saying
I don't miss you guys
Yeah, I can't believe it's already been a month
Wait, 20 more subs until 10k, you're joking
Sorry, I'm shrinking because I'm trying to look at my sub count
I can't even find it
It doesn't matter
But I can't believe we already achieved these numbers in such a short amount of time
As you guys know, it was my goal and my debut to hit 10k
And we're so close
And I just want to say thank you
You guys are wonderful
Thank you for renewing your memberships for the next month
I'm happy that I'm worthy enough for you to still give me your money and support me
But...
Yeah, I just...
A bit loud, turn down your damn headphones, bro
I switched them out from my 3D oh my
I literally just have no words besides
I just have the feeling of thankfulness and gratefulness and affection
It's crazy
Congrats on nearly getting 10k, thank you
But yeah, thank you members for renewing
I can't wait to come back
And...
I can't wait to come back and do a fun member stream for you guys
I think, yeah, we're gonna watch Salt Burn together
I was gonna do a karaoke, but I technically already did a karaoke
And that's up on the channel, so I'm like, I'll plan something a little bit better next time
Instead of that weird spare of the moment thing
Yeah, I'll miss you guys
Yes, the armpit pic for 10k is still the reward
I have it on standby, ready to be released into the ether
That is my alt account
Oh my goodness
Let me look at the doughnose
Oh my god
Alright, thank you for the $50 tip Ms. Morgan
The stream has meant more to me than I can properly describe
Being trans, I've often mourned the childhood I never got to have
This has let me experience a part of that childhood that I never thought I'd get to have
Thank you big sis, anytime
It's like, I'm an only child, so I never had anybody teach me to do makeup or do makeup on me
So I kind of wanted to share that moment with you
We both have an experience that we really never had before
I'm happy you enjoyed it, thank you so much for your support
Yeah, I know when you grow up a certain way
And you realize you don't have the same experiences that the average person may have
It's very bitter, but then it's better sweet because then you can always experience what's down the line
It takes a little bit more time, but you get there
Alright
Let me see, is there anything else?
Nope, I think that was it
And $5 from a super chat, let me see where that went
Where'd that super chat go?
What are you, thank you Falling Floor
What are you doing step sister?
I'm putting makeup on ya, so I'll make you my bitch
Did your mom not teach you?
No, not really
My mom didn't want me to wear makeup
I taught myself how to do makeup
And again, makeup that my mom does is a lot different from the makeup that I did
If you look through the years about how makeup has changed in the last few decades
It's very significant, not really significant
My mom just throw blue eyeshadow over her eyes in mascara
What am I going to do in the evenings while you're gone?
You can study your Bible, but you just can't finish the verse, that's what you can do
I won't have Shebe to keep me company at work for the next week
I know, and I won't have you
What the fuck?
Oh, it's me because I'm bouncing my leg because I'm anxious
Because I don't want to leave, I don't want to end the stream
Shebe's going hard into the fentanyl
I honestly, I just wanted to do that because I just kind of wanted to pamper you
And men don't usually get that opportunity to be pampered and kind of taken care of
And I can tell that a lot of you took a lot from this, from the skincare portion
And honestly, in my opinion, I think men should be able to wear makeup
Not in a huge way how women wear it
But you should be able to wear makeup in terms of like, oh, maybe you want to contour your jaw
Or maybe you want to conceal some zits
I feel like that should be more normalized
I thought I was a cat, no, it's me bouncing my leg
But yeah, I just wanted to pamper you and remind you that you're loved and I care for you
And then I'll brush your hair, I'll make your skin nice
And I'll do your makeup and I'll give you kisses
200 plus people quite a lot of people don't really brush your hair
I just, like for me personally, I'm a very, whoa
I got really confused because I thought that was USD
And I was gonna piss myself
Thank you so much for the donovie for Supa
Wow, that's so kind of you
Yeah, I was literally like, what?
And I was gonna, I was literally, yeah, everybody else
I'm happy, I'm happy I'm not the only one
I have to, I don't know how much that is in USD
But thank you
If it was 100K or otherwise
Yeah, $6, yes
What, what is that from?
I don't know, what, um
What is that from?
Indonesia, oh, okay, got you, got you
Now a rich chatter should drop to 100K for the bit
I don't, I don't think I have anybody like that watching me
I don't, I don't think so
But just some random Arabian prince is like, yes, I like, I like this bunny
Here you are
Bill Gates, just like Tim Cook, just here you go
The one oil baron, his biding his time
Waiting for my birthday, Jonathan to occur
The bunny is delectable to 100K
100,000, yes
Hey, madame
No, for you guys are fine, don't worry about that
Giving, giving me money wouldn't, um, make me treat you any different
How small or large
Um, quick, everybody find a lottery ticket
It's okay, I'm poor too, we can be poor together
Yep
Um, what was I gonna say?
But, uh, I just, a part of me is just really, doesn't want to leave
I really feel like you guys, and you can make fun of me, I don't care
But I feel like you guys are gonna leave me and be like, oh, she's gone for a week
Let me go find another oh she, um, let me go find another streamer
And you just never come back to me and you never, you never want to, you never want anything to do with me again
And that scares me, I guess I have a fear of abandonment
Um, and I know some of you guys do too, cause you guys are scared that I'm leaving
But just know that I'm also scared to be leaving cause I'm, I'm the same exact way that I'm bouncing my legs so hard
I need to calm down, um, I need to just like, I'm just like, let me just stim, let me just stim
I am, I am needy streamer, that is, that is indeed me
But, I have to remind myself and I look at your comments and I look at your, your sweet tweets at me
Um, and I just remind myself, no, that's not true, don't let the breadworm, the breadworms, the brainworms, win
They, they love me as much as I care for them
I remember, I was scrolling on Twitter and I saw a tweet
And it's one of those like, from one of those stupid accounts, a tweet romance stuff
But it said, I know a love like the one I want exists because I have that love within myself
And I want to give it to someone, something like that
And I think, I think that kind of just, it's you guys, like I know you guys give me the same energy back
You match my freak, so to speak
Um, so I'm just very thankful for you
Uh, please don't forget me or be sad in my absence, I'll still be around, I'll try to do a Twitter space
I'll have short settles go up
Again, I am profusely apologizing because I did not have time with everything that I was doing
To, um, finish the ASMR video, but I will do it immediately when I come back home
Um, I have some fun stuff planned when I come back, some script writing, Zatsu
Upon my return, we can write a script together
Uh, obviously I want to play Elden Ring, going to watch Saltburn
Uh, have some collabs, I've been touching base with a lot of really sweet, amazing girls, VTubers
And I can't wait to spend time with them, oh they're very sweet
And I appreciate them for giving me a chance to just like hang out and be cool
I'll leave you guys voice messages, I'll leave like little voice messages on my ultimate Twitter
I wish I could give you guys a hug
Like I think cause I need a hug right now
I'm so scared to leave, I don't want to leave
Mama raised proper men, we are here to stay, I hope so
It's gonna be so hard to enjoy myself because I realize I enjoy myself the most when I'm with you
And I'm trying not to cry but that's the truth
Oh my big baby, you've had me, I've been had, I'm a big baby and you know wipe my eyes
But yes, I'm giving hugs right back
Hug the mic, hug the mic, hug the mic
Yeah
You guys know I'm a softy but like I think that's what makes me a good dom
Because I'll be soft, I'll be sweet and isn't it so much better when you have someone like me just like tearing your ass up, you know
When you have someone like me to put you in your place and make you beg and bark on your knees
Use you as a foot stool, hit you with my crop, oh that reminds me
Something came in today, I want to show you guys, hold on
Oh
My neighbor was like, oh do you want me to start bringing up your mail for you because I see you get mail a lot
And I'm like, no you don't have to at all, oh crap my cat's vet just called me
I hope they leave a message, it's probably with Reina's blood work
Um
Oh gosh I hope it's not like bad news because I'm gonna lose it if it's bad news man
I don't want to deal with that right now
But yeah I told my neighbor, please don't get my stuff
Why is this in a plastic bag? This is just a big ziploc bag
I don't know how I feel about that
It's fine
Can you guess what this item is?
Mmm it smells interesting
Hold on there's like zip ties around it, I need scissors
Do I have a knife over here?
I swear to God I thought I had a knife over here
I might not be able to do $10,000 but I could do $10, you're fine
Thank you for your first soup, you're so sweet
You take, yeah my mom will be watching over my cats
And I also have the, what's it called, the cat cam
So I'll be able to see them and I can shoot treats at them
Sorry I'm looking for scissors
Scissors
Zip ties
I will leave, I need some more, I'm gonna miss you so much
You jump into the freaking bridge
Alright
How am I gonna use this? This isn't, I feel like I'm gonna hurt myself with it
Like what do I do with this? I should have never accepted this gift
I already hit all my toys, the shoes finally came in today
It's not shabari, can you hear it?
Be careful with the whip, that's right it's a whip
Can I, oh, can you hear that?
Can you hear it?
Can you hear the whip? This thing is so big, I have a giant ass whip
Oh
It is a four or five foot long bull whip?
Um, yeah, no, I'm good, don't worry, I'm not, I'm not doing anything
But yeah, I have a whip now, I feel like fucking catwoman
I wanna do a catwoman cosplay, Michelle Pfeiffer style
I can just twirl this around me like a motherfucker
Oh, thank you so much for the soupa
I thought that was $500,000
That just keeps freaking me out, cause I like, I pause and I'm like, okay, wait, no, I'm fine
I was just like, uh, that was just terrified me
I would have been like, please, please don't give me that much money
Thank you, thank you so much of you
So kind, I just hit my hands on my microphone
But yeah, I got a whip now, I don't know where I'm gonna put this
Where do I put this big ass whip?
Boomi, you want it?
Take a little sniff
Boomi's sniffing
Oh my god, I hope my mom doesn't fight into this big ass whip
I don't know
I think soupas can only go to $500
Keep in mind, if you do a soupa, most of it, most, most of it, I'm suddenly Australian, um, most
It'll go to YouTube, so Streamlabs is the best way to go
Say it's for horseback riding and rodeo lessons
No, my parents know what I do for a living, guys
They know what I do, they know that I'm a lewd voice actress
No way, you're just telling me that now, I thought that's usually, I thought that was common knowledge
Do you like the whip, madam? Please be careful, the cats, don't you want it? Yes I do
Yes I do, thank you Taft Potential, I do like it a lot
Wait, I can't even see, if anybody did don't know normally, I can't even see Streamlabs because I don't have it open
Yeah
Yippee
YouTube takes 30%
Cat toy, cat toy, do it
What do you think, Reyna? What do you think about this?
Ooh, Reyna's excited, Reyna wants to play with the whip
Ooh, you like that Reyna? She's like, she's like trying to grab it with her paw
I don't know if you could hear her, she's on like the plastic bag it came in
No, Reyna let it go, Reyna let it go, I have to clip their claws after this
Reyna let go, I shouldn't have taught you to play with that
Alright, I wonder what this would feel like to hit someone with a bend over
Okay, where do I put this? Where do I hide with it? I don't know where to hide with it
Okay, I think I hid it
I shoved it in a place in my closet, I hope my mom doesn't notice
Oh, I don't want to leave, I don't want to leave, I don't want to leave, I just want to be with you
But I have to go pack
I'm 10K? Are you 10K?
No way, we hit 10K
Oh my god, it's okay, we're gonna get called, but we hit 10K
Holy shit, we hit 10K
Oh my god
I can't believe we hit 10K live on stream, that's insane
How did my thing go up to me?
What the heck?
10K, let's go!
There's 10K harlots that love me
Oh, I'm so proud of us, again, it's 10K of you
You did this, you wonderful harlots, you...
Now you get an armpit picture
Are you happy? You get to see my armpit
You get to see my armpit
Armpit, armpit
Okay, I made a promise that if we hit 10K, which I didn't think would be this soon
I'd post a picture of my armpit mole, because I have an armpit beauty mark
If you're new here, by the way, I'm brown
So my armpit will not be a beautiful alabaster porcelain white
I am a brown girl, I am tan
So you'll get a nice tan pit
Armpits are like the five hot as well, as you're not really getting my armpit
Like it was just the mole, I said
I'm kind of shy to show you guys my armpit
Because armpits are not as pretty as they are drawn
I do not have a vagina looking armpit
All armpits are beautiful
Because like, you know how they draw them looking like succulent, wet, smooth as a fucking slug
Like, I almost had a turtle for some reason
Guys, I shave my armpits, I have like little hair stubble
And when you're brown, your pits are more melanated
So I got some melanated pits
I think in the picture you also get a little bit of my hair
But again, I only reveal, I don't normally, like, I'm a VTuber first and foremost, everyone
I only do like hand cams and thigh cams, foot cams, what have you
And like little cosplays that show off my RTX form
Only for milestones, it is not on a daily basis, by the way
I'm not a flush tuber, I'm not, as they say, a twitch thought that's come to ruin VTuber
That is not me, I only do it because I like to give you guys little treats and you ask for it
So, yeah, you're never seeing my face, I am sheebie
Soon enough, my tanness will reflect it in my 2D form, my true form if you will
So, yeah, 100k, we get the other pit, well, wouldn't it be 20k?
20k, I don't have anything on my other pit though, so, I don't know
My emotes
Yeah, I know, I need to figure that out
When we get eyeball pics, you'll never get an eyeball pic because that is a part of my face
I'm sorry
What was the next milestone?
I'll probably say, I don't know
Yay, new members, neck reveal, guys, I'm not
You're never seeing my eyes, you're never seeing my mouth, you're never seeing my ear
Next milestone, 100k
Neck reveal is wild, it will just be just brown skin
Oh, thank you, LGF, thank you for the 50 gifted
Absolutely insane, amazing way to celebrate getting 10k
Okay, I'll say it, I guess you are my little pog champ
Okay, like, brown woman she means
Everybody's like, yay, more, more gifted
Thank you so much
LGF
I feel so bad for my lurkers that like, post because they're like, did I win?
And then, but the gotcha, the gotcha did not grant them what they wanted
I'm just here long for the ride
One the gotcha
Remember, if you guys want to, yeah, it's 50, it's going to take a bit
If you guys still want to, if you want to watch Salt Burn with me
When we do the watch along, when I come back, you can always upgrade to the member tier
Because this is just emotes, and you have to be
Hell yeah, Castle Hellford, a dollar, thank you, so sweet
I'll heart that for you, what a sweet little castle
I can do a lot with one doll, I can buy myself some candy
I can get myself an espresso shot, probably not
Looking forward to the bathtub seat and salt, me too, me too
If you haven't seen Salt Burn, do not look anything up, that is an order
You're so beautiful and gorgeous, oh thank you, oh stop it
You're going to make me blush, oh goodness
Good, good, good, you better be scared, you better be scared
No spoilers, no spoilers
I'm debating whether or not to fart in the mic
A little cheeky brat for 10k
Are you going to watch the boys finale, oh shit
Oh no, I won't be able to watch the boys finale
Oh wait, no, I don't leave till the late
I don't leave till the, I'm not going to say when
Nobody charge my flight please, I should, maybe if I can
Watch it on the flight, oh that's true, I can watch it on the flight
Yeah I'll do, well no, I'll just be screaming the entire time
What if somebody gets like, is like some really gory shit
Or like sexual shit is happening in the finale
And I'm just sitting there watching it with some poor normal person
A sweet little lady looking over to my iPad
And somebody's getting like finger bangs
Or whatever
Wait, wait, are you a, are you a, are you a, a role player?
I think role player chatters are some of my favorite chatters
Okay the person who proposed role plays this Friday
Now I got some of the role plays of Sans
Now I can just follow
That's how I'll read your comments from now on
Sitting next to a nun
I'm sitting next to a nun and we're doing it
On the plane in front of everyone
I can't go that deep
Mile Halakai Club with the sweet old nun that'll be sitting next to me
I saw an old guy watching straight up corn on his phone in an aisle seat
Geez
Oh my god
I, I forget where I'm sitting on the right
All I know is that my plane ride back is gonna be shitty
Because I'm in the middle of my plane ride back
On my plane ride there, I'm in the window
To the walls
I thought it was a mistake to eat snacks while watching the web viewer tech night episode
Oh that was fun
Yes it is, I should be Undertale
I wanted to play Undertale at one point because I think the voice acting would be fun
But I would not want to play the whole game
And it's really hard to get through
Because I would just want to do Papyrus' voice
Make him sound like Skeletor like everybody else does
You've solved my puzzle
You're still on season 3? Hurry up
By the power of puzzles
Wonderland's dungeon has definitely funded my tech night with all the equipment
You think I'm funded by a man who runs prisons
And is a little white nationalist
It's rage inducing
I never thought it was rage inducing
Great comment, thank you
Literally my OG name before I got the daddy sign on Bob in it from Bob from Temmie
I still, I know I'm mentally ill because sometimes I'll just go
Hi I'm Temmie, just like randomly
Hi, hi I'm Temmie
Hi, I'm Temmie
I just do that
I just do that, normally
Hi, I'm Chibi
I'm literally I'm Sans and I'm Temmie
Hi, I'm Temmie
Temmie Flakes
Hoives
And her thoughts just working out whenever they feel like it
Because sometimes I'm the type of person where if I see like a word
And it reminds me of like a quote
I'm gonna say the quote out loud
And I'm just impulsive like that
I'm glad I'm not the only one from what the chat is saying
My undyne impression will just sound like a really hot tomboy
And then like my alphys impression will be like
Hi Undyne
I was wondering if you want to go back to my laboratory and watch anime
Well I don't know, should we alphys?
I gotta kill these guys over here
Something like that, I don't know
Um
Sometimes when I think of a move in a word I just automatically start doing it
Yeah, same
We love the gay fish
That's the voice you gave Dusa, you're right
I did give Dusa that voice
Can we get a so sorry impression?
I don't know what that references to
Is that a character within Undertale?
I played Deltarune as well
And I loved, I really like Deltarune
I have to fin, I think they, did they finish the like newer episodes of Deltarune?
I don't know
And he put my 3D away, it's like in my face
I can barely see the screen
State fast, rip fast
I can't stay there
Toriel British
Does everybody make Toriel British?
I probably would then
Um, I baked you a butterscotch cake
Cake?
I baked you, I baked you a butterscotch pie
I hope you think it would be really delightful
I worked really hard on it, you know
Um, I think you belong here, just fine
Chapter 2's out, okay
I never, I didn't read, I didn't read
I didn't do Chapter 2 then
Great CC voice
Has the Brit not bad
You should go see, I think I retweeted it
It's not an actual short, but I kind of want to upload it as an actual short
And give credit to the person who made it
I did a whole British bit
Um, with my Goexla
I can do a British accent very well
Cause I really like period, um, TV shows and films
And I would just watch British stuff with my mom all the time
Um, I also used to watch a lot of Love Island, so
Butterscotch cinnamon pie, it was good
I remember one of the characters in the game, Sundar Plain and Sundare
That's right, yeah, the one that like kind of like blushes at you
And she's like, I love that the characters in that game are just great
British Papa
Can you do a British chop though?
I can't really do, like, particular
Uh, what's it called? Regional accents that well?
It's like, I can be either really posh or really Londoner
Like, oh, bro, you want a tussle, yeah?
Well, you know, I see a fit bird out there
And I said, you know, I'm a bagger, I'm a pull this fit bird
And then you swooped in, bro
And you just took a rifle under me
And I fucking hate you for that, you're fucking bloody wanker for that
That's all I'm gonna say, bro
That's all I'm gonna say
Went Scottish there, I did, sometimes I'll go Scottish
The way I go Scottish is I'll either say
If you had the chance to change your fate, would ya?
Or what are you doing in my swamp?
Or I'll say, um, reeflings
I just channel scrawny
Yeah, I just sound like a roadman, yeah
Yeah
Okay, what did you say?
Am I being hit on by, uh
Skull in forever
I can't do, would ya know
I can't do a Australian accent, though
I can't really do it, no, oh, no
I need to like listen to Aimee more
Absolutely, sometimes like during our Left 4 Dead 2 collab
With Aimee and Reia in Azura
I literally just sat there and I would be quiet
Because I wanted to listen to Aimee talk so I could emulate her voice
One time recently I was in the shower
And I was listening to, uh, I think like a Neander's clip
And I would just, I would, I'm a freak, guys
I was just sitting, standing in the shower, brushing out my hair
You know, doing what I'm doing
And then Neander's would say something
And I just would try to say in the same exact voice
Uh, hi everyone
Hi, hi
I, um, I can't, she like kinda goes to the front of it
And it's kind of in the back of it
I can't even do it right now
And I've tried to do like Shia Lily's voice
Shimi, I don't really want you to leave, but no, you need to go pack, fuck, you're right
Listen to laser beam for this truly an accident
Come on, come on, yeah
I need to, I'm trying to work on it
Yeah, I just really want to be able to voice act and do cool impressions
Like fuckin' Elizabeth Bloodflame
Uh, I really, if I listen to, if you give me a voice
Like I figured out I can do Kiara's voice
And I can do Mori Kaliope's voice
So that's interesting
Now you're not free, you're just dedicated to VA
Also I knew a girl who stayed out two hours in the shower
Cause she has a bathtub markers to meet art in the shower
That's actually kinda cool
I didn't know that was a thing
Yeah, she's a fucking god for that
Um, for her, for her impressions
Uh, yeah, I was trying to do, like I was trying to figure out how to do
I think I can do Doki Bird's voice too
I realized one time when I was watching her a lot
Uh, and one of my streams, this is one of my, my appeal
I realized I was accidentally talking like her
Because I just, I have echolalia, so like when I listen to something
Enough, I just start to mimic it and replicate it
And I was like doing her laugh
And I was like, I can't do it right now
I don't have the laugh down
Again, I have to listen to a voice and repeat it constantly
And I don't, I don't listen to the VTubers enough
That I want to learn imitations of, that I can just do it on command
I literally have to listen to a voice clip and then I can get into it
I could probably do Kobo's voice, actually
I'm not gonna, cause I can go that high
Like I can do, I can do Fuwawa Mokoko
Cause I can go that high
I, I realized I can do higher voices better than I can do lower voices
Which doesn't make any sense, cause my voice is naturally in a lower register
So I don't, I don't get that
Why?
I literally made a friend crap himself
I dressed up as a slender man and then he was, what?
Off topic, but okay
It's a lack of an Adam's apple
Yes, I 100% have more control of my head voice in Volsetto
Yes, I definitely do
Cause they're like, they, like, so there's a lot of VTubers that are like, breathe out a lot when they're talking
They go, like I noticed when I was trying to mimic Neanna's voice
She talks out and she breathes out like this
And when she, she gets a little bit high cause she has a naturally soft and higher voice
But I can't, but she like, breathes out
At least you don't practice your belting
Yeah, I don't think my neighbors would like that
Sounds like a mix of mocha kawawa, yeah, right, cause I need to listen to them to really like, again, to be able to do it
And like, and Shy Lily's is in the back of the throat
Hi, I can't, I can't even fucking do it
I like how she speaks like that, that's me, I know, right?
I love, VTubers have such interesting voices because a lot of them are voice actors themselves
And, you know, they became popular because they have very distinct, unique voices
For example, Doki Bird has such a distinct and unique laugh and that's just something
One of the things that made her so lovable was her such, she has such a cute laugh
And so it's so fun to mimic VTubers voices because they're all so very different and like, very unique
Me, I just, I kind of, again, I've gotten compared to like, like a deeper Maury, Calliope before
And like some other VTubers because I speak in a kind of a deeper register
Got a Master of Gen Maids, I can do Icy
Hi everybody, it's Icy Snowpaws
Today we're going to be doing some Guild Wars
I love my Dadas
My Icy is good, she has a little bit of vibration and then you just have to do some like a European accent
Um, and I don't know if I can do Amy's voice
I have to listen to Amy's voice to do it
I'm trying to think of like, I'm trying to repeat her voice in my head right now
I can go as high as Amy
And then I can be a Zara Dule
I'm working on a Zara's voice because she has a breathy voice
But I can't seem to get her Lisp down because she has a Lisp, but I don't notice it
And then Zara was just like, no, I do have a Lisp, I'm like, I don't pick up on it, so I can't do that
Um, it's a decent, I mean, yeah, no, I can 100% get Amy's voice
I will just need to practice
Um, Skinwalker skills
Is Vela actually, no, actually we're all strongies personas
I'm strongy
Are you fucking kidding me right now?
I can't even, she has a little bit
So, so, so, so I was wondering if, no, I have to listen to her voice
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Yeah, that sounded like I see, it's because I still have Icy's voice in my head
Yeah, I'm trying to get Mercy's laugh down
I can't even do it
So, so, so, so, I have to like, I don't even, because Mercy's voice is similar to mine in terms of like
She's like a little bit higher than mine
Yeah, Mercy's laugh is in the chest
Yeah
What took you so long to come back, granddaughter?
Bye, thank you
Mercy's fill-
Yeah
Imagine a whole VTuber company that's just in person with multiple personas
I am, I think there's actually a company that's a VTuber like that
I know like, Alias has her two little like ghosty friends that she does voices for, which is very impressive
And then I believe that Clotho, who just debuted in
Mythos is actually technically playing three people
So it's pretty cool
Collabs would be tricky
I think there's a running joint, the floor, because everybody in his closet
That is funny
Oh
I'll leave in three minutes, I'll leave in three minutes, let me find someone to read
Oh, Strony is playing, yeah, I'll read Strony
She's playing supermarket simulator, I hope she isn't fucking hiking up her prices or something
I didn't know
Strony is very impressed with how far along my Scottish accent has come since I first spoke to her
Now because I since I talk to her more often
Well, my neck isn't quite on my body, hold on, let me lean back when I lean forward
Wait, is Strony not streaming? Was that, what the heck?
Am I tripping?
Was that just like an old thing? Was that old?
Strony rated me, you're right, I don't know why
I don't know why that just
What the hell?
It didn't reflect on my screen that she stopped streaming
I'm so, I'm tired, leave me alone, leave me alone
See, that's why I put that there, that's why I put that thing there
Oh wait, Phoenix, I didn't see that, $20 tip
Check her out, CB, not just on the 10k, but on all the other dreams that are and will be coming true
Oh, thank you, Phoenix
So kind, thank you so much
It's because I don't have the donor alerts on because I'm in my ASMR scene
Let's see, let's see there
Let me find a real Bonnie Lassie for ya
Let's go outside the Corpo
Let's find someone real cute
Erm, what the shibidi? I can't find my own video
Oh god, please
I like lost you guys
Where'd you guys go?
I'm gonna miss you, this guy, outside of you all is scary
Erm, what the shibidi?
Erm, what the shibidi, what the heck
I don't know what I'll do with space
I'm gonna miss you guys, I'll miss you so hard
I'm gonna miss you so freakin' hard
I don't see Zer streaming, what are you talking about?
He has lied to me
I'm going to raid this person
Umi?
Wait, yep
I'll raid them
Yippee
They just came back from Diddy World
Is there a member? Yeah, I can't raid a member stream guys, that's just not how that works
Alright, bye guys
Kiss the mic, kiss the mic, kiss the mic
Bye
So you can just say
Diddy World
I'll type it for you
Raid
Alright, not Diddy World
Diddy World
Yeah, perfect, Diddy World
Bye guys, kisses
And now I have to go post my armpit
See you guys in a bit
See you guys soon
Okay
Bye, love you, bye
Bye
I don't want to leave, bye
I love you